In 1914, an Archduke of Austria-Hungary was
shot by a Serbian nationalist.
This led, after a series of nations signing
treaties with other nations, to one of the
bloodiest conflicts ever fought.
A war that was unlike any that had been fought
at the time.
Trench combat, mud, and sandbags, newer, deadlier
advancements in the art of warfare, vile,
incurable and fatal diseases, and months upon
months of misery, all while trapped in dark,
dank dugouts.
The Great War, the First World War, it’s
gone by many names since its ceasefire in
1918, and while there aren’t many left of
the generation that remembers it, there are
still plenty of scars left on the world that
remind us of the horrors.
But there’s one that seems to be keeping
those wounds fresh, reminding us that war
is, indeed, Hell as that rough beast slouches
towards its destination.
This is SCP-2574, what appears from the outset
to be nothing more than a stone sculpture
of a lion, comprised of sandstone… and living
tissue.
Standing at around twelve meters tall, SCP-2574
is much more than a mere statue.
In fact, it’s a living creature.
After all, this is the SCP Foundation we’re
talking about here, where inanimate objects
are rarely inanimate at all, or will at least
possess some form of anomalous properties
setting apart anything ordinary and thus drawing
the interest of the Foundation.
SCP-2574 is similar in that regard, and not
just for being a living statue creature.
For one, the anomaly is capable of movement,
albeit at a gradual rate that only progresses
between three and five kilometers per day.
Attempts by the Foundation to slow or halt
the movement of SCP-2574 have been so far
unsuccessful, as it seems that any obstacle
placed in its path are unable to deter it.
This includes both man-made and naturally
occurring obstructions, meaning there is little
that can be deployed to keep SCP-2574 physically
contained.
Even if a body of water is in its path, the
entity can swim at a rate of between two and
three kilometers per day, and will normally
either crush or climb over any obstacle on
land.
At the previous annual budgeting meeting,
the top minds of the Foundation’s accounting
department revealed to an infuriated O5 Council
that SCP-2574 had been responsible for an
estimated total of twenty-five point three
million US dollars in damages since its discovery.
The second most pressing matter raised during
that presentation was the one hundred and
twelve deaths and a further six hundred and
twenty-five injuries the anomaly had also
caused.
Despite pleas from the Ethics Committee, the
Foundation accountants were still adamant
that the cost of damages was more significant.
Now, a number of prevailing questions might
be plaguing you regarding SCP-2574.
For one, what does this creature want?
If it has freedom of movement and can’t
be physically obstructed by the Foundation,
then is it just aimlessly wandering free and
causing wanton destruction, or does it have
a specific want or goal it seeks to attain?
And for another, what does an almost forty-foot-tall
lion have to do with World War One?
Well, it might surprise you to know that SCP-2574
has everything to do with the Great War – literally,
everything.
And as for a goal?
It has one, or rather, it has a specific destination
it seems to be gradually heading towards,
and if it makes it all the way there, it could
spell disaster for the entire globe.
In fact, it could plunge us back into one
of the most devastating conflicts the world
has ever seen.
Can you guess which one?
SCP-2574 possesses a wide array of latent
anomalous effects, beyond its general functionality
and movement.
Above the sandstone lion creature, it is constantly
surrounded by a flock of around six thousand
birds of prey.
Any that find themselves flying into the path
of SCP-2574 are assimilated into the growing
flock, designated as SCP-2574-1.
The mass of birds is fixated on attacking
SCP-2574, swooping low to strike at its smooth
muscle tissue with using their beaks and talons.
This, however, seems to do little to deter
SCP-2574 from making progress, as the anomaly
constantly regenerates from physical damage
it incurs from SCP-2574-1.
Perhaps the most notable and noticeable of
SCP-2574’s anomalous properties is the effect
it has on its surroundings as it progresses
toward its destination.
The area around SCP-2574 will undergo a physical
transformation in response to the presence
of the lion.
This transformation results in the nearby
region temporarily becoming a World War One-era
combat zone.
The ground below becomes riddled with trenches
carved through the earth, thick muddy bogs,
and coiled, razor-sharp nets of barbed wire
litter the area.
The change triggered by SCP-2574 is hardly
just a cosmetic one either.
The Foundation have observed a number of First
World War-related manifestations that occur
in the wake of SCP-2574.
Man-made land masses like trenches and dugouts
will appear nearby, the front lines reappearing
after more than a century.
Weaponry from the era is also present following
the arrival of SCP-2574, and this isn’t
just limited to firearms.
World War One was one of the earliest large-scale
conflicts in history wherein both sides deployed
aerial attacks through the use of bi-planes,
as well as chemical warfare.
As a result, signs of these can also be found
whenever SCP-2574 is nearby.
But again, the transformation SCP-2574 brings
about is not just limited to recreating battlefields.
What some of you may not know is the Great
War did not so much revolve around a core
idealistic difference between both sides as
its successor did.
Instead, the First World War was a geopolitical
grudge match between large global superpowers
attempting to make grandiose displays of their
amassed military strength.
The assassination of Archduke Franz Ferdinand
of Austria at the hands of a Serbian extremist
group was the catalyst that set off a chain
reaction of events that ultimately led to
war.
As a result of this, SCP-2574’s anomalous
influence also extends to the social and political
state of the areas it enters.
A country that the sandstone leonine entity
enters will suffer a rapid change in its local
population’s mentality.
The ordinary people living there will start
to experience a great degree of discontent
towards their government, while the ruling
powers of said country will increase its use
of force against its own civilians.
This effect is more noticeably potent when
SCP-2574 interacts with countries that were
directly involved in the First World War,
increasing levels of civil unrest and discontentment
among the population.
These are often countered with worryingly
increased levels of police brutality, along
with governments enacting aggressive foreign
policies and sometimes antagonizing other
countries, as if they are eager to fight.
These effects don’t necessarily worsen the
closer SCP-2574 gets to a particular country
but do seem to increase the more it approaches
its predicted destination.
And where is that, you might ask?
The Foundation have calculated that, based
on SCP-2574’s trajectory since its emergence
back in 2012, the entity is heading for the
city of Sarajevo, the capital city of Bosnia
and Herzegovina.
What possible reason could SCP-2574 have for
wanting to venture towards this specific Bosnian
city?
Well, one cursory glance at the history of
Sarajevo will give you the answer: it’s
where the assassination of Archduke Franz
Ferdinand took place – the event commonly
attributed with starting the First World War.
The transformative effects SCP-2574 has on
its surroundings began when the leonine leviathan
first appeared and commenced its journey towards
Sarajevo on December 24th, 2012.
Since then, the SCP Foundation has been closely
monitoring the sandstone creature’s movements,
and attempting to log all of the anomalous
effects it has had over the course of making
its way closer to the site of Fraz Ferdinand’s
assassination.
Over five thousand kilometers away, to the
east of Kazakhstan’s capital, Astana, SCP-2574
caused an unusual World War One anomalous
effect.
Any written works published in either Russian
or Kazakh began to randomly feature passages
from Irish poet W.B.
Yeats.
These extracts from his body of work ranged
from single sentences to entire poems being
featured in other writers’ publications,
regardless of author or genre.
Yeats, for anyone unfamiliar, was widely considered
one of the greatest poets of the 20th Century.
However, unlike the authors of numerous poems
and songs to come out of the First World War,
W.B.
Yeats was never directly involved in the conflict
itself, and didn’t write much about it,
barring a few notable exceptions.
But more on him in a moment.
When SCP-2574 approached Russia, things started
to escalate.
Clouds of deadly chlorine gas – an early
World War One chemical weapon – began forming
in rural areas throughout Europe, that couldn’t
be dispersed for days at a time.
As soon as the towering anomaly got close
enough, Russian military forces began launching
a series of drone strikes and aerial bombardments
targeting SCP-2574.
When these attacks failed, tensions mounted
with bordering countries, the situation only
getting worse when it was discovered through
an intelligence leak that Russia was planning
a nuclear strike against the creature.
A move that likely could’ve spelled disaster
for the neighboring countries.
SCP-2574, of course, sustained no damage,
and continued on its course.
Given that they couldn’t physically contain
SCP-2574, the Foundation was forced to think
outside the box when it came to coming up
with some kind of solution.
There were already too many eyewitnesses aware
of the leonine leviathan’s existence to
consider the administering of amnestics, even
on a large scale.
The fact was, too many people already knowing
about SCP-2574 would make such a move pointless.
The best that the Foundation could do to combat
– if not counteract – the effects of SCP-2574,
was to work directly with governments affected
by the creature’s World War One transformative
effects, to try and repair the damage left
in the anomaly’s wake, and ease the tension
and violence it caused.
It became the Foundation’s job to deter
any country planning an armed military response
to the presence of SCP-2574, as any such strike
would endanger both their military and civilian
populations, while causing no damage to the
anomaly.
In the interest of trying to solve the problems
posed by SCP-2574 reverting parts of Europe
to hellish First World War era battlefields,
the Foundation made a rare agreement to collaborate
with another large organization specializing
in the anomalous: the Global Occult Coalition.
Working directly with the GOC, their goal
was to create a large-scale memetic countermeasure
that would effectively reset the toll SCP-2574
had exacted on global psychology, by altering
people’s temperaments and creating mass
political unrest as it progressed towards
the Bosnian capital.
However, given the tense history between the
SCP Foundation and the Global Occult Coalition,
their attempts at creating a memetic countermeasure
are still ongoing, since neither group wants
the other to engage them in full-scale memetic
warfare.
As such, the proposed countermeasure will
consist of two parts, with neither organization
being able to replicate the other’s half.
Meanwhile, SCP-2574’s progress across Europe
was responsible for a number of other significant
changes, physically, socially, and politically
recreating the conditions of the First World
War.
Poppies, a flower that has since become synonymous
with the remembrance of the conflict, began
to grow in regions within Russia where they
wouldn’t naturally occur.
This included within urban locations, the
red flowers sprouting in and around buildings.
As a result of such a high-profile anomaly
causing such widespread unrest to spread,
a number of religious cults centered around
SCP-2574 began to form.
While the living descendants of World War
One veterans began suffering from vivid hallucinations
that depicted their ancestor’s firsthand
experience of the fighting, these cults began
to amass more and more of those affected by
SCP-2574.
The SCP Foundation was able to observe some
of the sermons delivered by these religious
cults, who appeared to view the public appearances
of SCP-2574 as signs of an impending apocalypse.
“Come to us and embrace your salvation!”
one cult leader exclaimed in a sermon.
“Discover the words of the prophet Yeats,
who spoke the sacred truth that all of history
is a spiral, and that we have spiraled outwards
towards chaos!
Learn the true nature of the Second Coming!”
It appeared that some of these cults viewed
the poetry of W.B.
Yeats as prophetic in regards to SCP-2574.
They would often reference ‘The Second Coming’
which, interestingly, was the name of one
of his poems written in the aftermath of World
War One.
Yeats’ The Second Coming refers to a ‘rough
beast’ slouching towards Bethlehem.
The SCP Foundation has since uncovered some
erratic writings made by the poet before his
death, that allude to Bethlehem, despite no
record existing of him ever traveling there.
It is believed that Yeats somehow figured
out what SCP-2574 was, and that the closer
it gets to its destination, the more civilization
will spiral further out of control towards
total, all-consuming global chaos.
Further research by the Foundation also uncovered
a testimony made by Gavrilo Princip – the
Serbian man responsible for assassinating
Archduke Franz Ferdinand of Austria and thus
sparking the First World War.
Princip seems to have also had some knowledge
about SCP-2574, and apparently killed the
Archduke as a way to begin the creature’s
journey in order to make society more chaotic.
With SCP-2574 progressing worryingly closer
to the site of Franz Ferdinand’s assassination,
further chaos rapidly began to spread.
Anarchic sentiments took hold of most of Europe,
leading to an increased rate of violent encounters
between civilians and police in many countries,
including Ireland, France, Great Britain,
and Italy, with a number of these experiencing
widespread rioting in their major population
centers.
Any government or political party compelled
by SCP-2574 to openly espouse the same anarchist
sentiments were soon seeing a rapid increase
in their public approval, gaining more popularity
in polls than their opposition.
As a result of these heightened tensions between
the public and the governments of their countries,
assassination attempts of politicians saw
an alarming increase of around sixty percent.
SCP-2574 caused countries that had existing
hostile relations to engage in armed skirmishes
at their borders, with at least one of these
battles occurring every two weeks, and each
time, threatening to spark a much larger scale
conflict.
Thanks to the anomaly’s effects, the international
tensions, dissolving alliances between countries,
and adoption of nationalism – which were
all factors leading to the start of the Great
War – were beginning to rapidly spread once
again.
By the time SCP-2574 was around five hundred
and fifty kilometers from Sarajevo, people
began to experience injuries common among
soldiers during World War One.
Many patients would die during surgery, only
for their bodies to disappear shortly afterwards.
Conflict erupted between Ireland and England,
and as SCP-2574 entered Bosnia and Herzegovina,
many began to report suffering intense dreams
about the anomaly.
A number of these reports seemed to state
that SCP-2754 was attempting to communicate
with them, and multiple websites began logging
the sandstone lion’s appearance in these
dreams.
And things will only get worse the closer
SCP-2574 gets Sarajevo.
SCP-2754 contains the raw energy of World
War One, one of the most catastrophic events
in human history, a global conflict with a
death toll in the tens of millions.
The SCP Foundation estimates it’ll reach
the site of Franz Ferdinand’s assassination
within a month.
And from that point, given the effect it’s
had on the rest of Europe, there’s only
one likely outcome when that rough beast slouches
towards its ultimate destination: war.
Now check out “SCP-186 - TO END ALL WARS”
and “WORLD WAR 2 GERMAN SCPS EXPLAINED”
for more!